[Música]
en France 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos en Estados Unidos
para conocer más del Apple Vision Pro
anunciado en su conferencia mundial de
desarrolladores se trata de un visor de
realidad mixta que combina nuestra
realidad con realidad aumentada
Apple Vision pro es un nuevo tipo de
ordenador que aumenta la realidad al
combinar a la perfección del mundo real
con el mundo digital es el primer
producto de Apple que ves y no Vision
Pro te resulta familiar pero es
completamente nuevo puedes ver aquí
interactuar con contenido digital al
igual que en tu espacio físico y
controlar visión Pro usando las
herramientas más naturales e intuitivas
sus ojos manos y voz
[Música]
con visión Pro ya no estás limitado por
una pantalla su entorno se convierte en
un Lienzo infinito
utilizar aplicaciones en cualquier lugar
ver todo tipo de contenido audiovisual y
sumergirse en los videojuegos son solo
algunas de las funciones que desempeña
este aparato una de las características
que más llamó la atención fue además de
la definición de las imágenes el rastreo
del ojo y la mano que las gafas no
vienen con mandos incorporados sino que
detectan Hacia dónde Mira el usuario y
se hace clic al juntar el índice y El
pulgar Asimismo al estar en una llamada
de facetime la otra persona aparece en
el campo visual como un avatar o versión
digital no es que sean los primeros en
llegar al mercado porque marcas como
meta y PlayStation ya han anunciado
productos similares Pero según expertos
los Vision Pro Sí marcarían una antes y
un después en la historia de Apple por
su tecnología de cómputo espacial
para lograr nuestras metas de desarrollo
movilidad y usabilidad utilizamos los
materiales más avanzados y livianos
posibles toda la parte frontal del
producto es una pieza singular de vidrio
tridimensional formado y laminado está
Pulido a una superficie óptica lo que le
permite actuar como una lente para la
vista y una amplia gama de cámaras y
sensores que necesitan tener una vista
del mundo
tiene 23 millones de píxeles en paneles
que son cada uno del tamaño de un sello
postal eso es más píxeles que un
televisor 4k para cada ojo para ampliar
estos paneles y envolverlos a su
alrededor se necesitaba una solución de
lentes sofisticada diseñamos una lente
personalizada de tres elementos con una
nitidez y Claridad increíbles es clave
Resaltar que el producto brinda una
experiencia que ningún otro producto de
Apple entregado hasta el momento los
responsables aseguran que es el
resultado de años de trabajo y permite
que cualquier ambiente que haya existido
en un iPhone se expanda y rodea al
usuario en tamaño real cuenta con cámara
3D y audio espacial además podrá usarse
como una pantalla externa de las
computadoras Mac los Vision Pro saldrán
al mercado a principios del próximo año
en Estados Unidos a un precio de 3.500
dólares muy por encima de sus
competidores
el punto de precio sigue siendo difícil
de justificar en un mercado de masas
pero desde una perspectiva de confianza
especialmente en un entorno empresarial
Apple tiene más confianza que meta creo
que desde el punto de vista del
consumidor ciertamente Apple tiene más
confianza si hablo mucho sobre el
aprendizaje automático de dispositivos
si hablo mucho sobre los datos
almacenados en el dispositivo
cambiamos de tema porque por primera vez
se retransmitieron imágenes en directo
desde Marte el objetivo era conmemorar
el vigésimo aniversario de la nave Marx
Express lanzado por la agencia espacial
Europea
esto es Marte y estas imágenes
aceleradas fueron las primeras
transmitidas desde el planeta en vivo
fueron filmadas desde la nave Marx
Express de la agencia espacial europea
como el planeta rojo está actualmente a
unos 300 millones de kilómetros de la
tierra a las imágenes de tomo un tiempo
en llegar 18 minutos la cámara de
seguimiento visual de 20 años de
antigüedad que lleva a bordo solo puede
captar imágenes cada 50 segundos aún así
es una Primicia histórica una forma de
marcar el 20 aniversario de Marx Express
[Música]
2 de junio de 2003 el lanzamiento fue un
gran Éxito para la ae aunque no todas
sus misiones han tenido éxito Mars
Express ha permitido a la agencia hacer
descubrimientos como confirmar con sus
sensores y el radar marsis que hay lagos
subterráneos en el planeta rojo también
ha detectado una nube sobre un volcán
Marciano la nave se utiliza para recoger
imágenes de los rovers en el suelo
Marciano y transmitirlas a la Tierra
esta vez la transmisión fue casi en
directo de una cámara que terminó su
misión original hace más de una década
cerramos en Reino Unido porque la
Inteligencia artificial Avanza en
numerosos Campos y uno de ellos es la
robótica hacer a los robots más
interesantes y capaces día a día este
que vemos en pantalla fue creado por
investigadores de la Universidad de
Cambridge y está entrenado para replicar
recetas tras ver a las personas
preparándolas lo que llaman programación
por demostración
imagina que diriges un restaurante y
llega un nuevo empleado puedes
capacitarlo muy fácilmente al hablarle o
mostrarle qué hacer eso es algo que no
podías hacer con un robot necesitabas a
alguien que lo programe programa
Así que ahora con la programación por
demostración puedes hacer lo mismo con
el
robots el robot usa visión computarizada
y analiza cada cuadro del video que
graba entonces es capaz de identificar
diferentes objetos o herramientas que
están en las manos de quien cocina
además de estudiar sus gestos faciales
Aún falta en su proceso de desarrollo
pero es responsable aseguran que podría
ser clave para automatizar la producción
de alimentos
así finalizamos este espacio a ustedes
gracias por su sintonía
[Música]